last night the democrats were supposed
to bring up the bipartisan
infrastructure bill for a vote they did
not because they could not get the
progressives on board and they couldn't
get the progressives on board because
they couldn't get the senate moderates
on board for their 3.5 trillion dollar
boondoggle meanwhile speeding down the
tracks is the debt ceiling so the debt
ceiling is supposed to be hit in
approximately the next couple of weeks
democrats are trying to get republicans
to sign on to a debt ceiling increase
republicans are saying we are not going
to allow you to take out a second credit
card knowing that you're about to blow
out the spending and so why would we
allow you to do that we need a sort of
restructuring deal here we need to make
sure that we get some sort of spending
concessions from you at this point which
has led the obama administration to make
the argument that we should get rid of
the debt ceiling once and for all so to
understand why the debt ceiling is kind
of important you have to understand the
history of how spending has been done in
the united states historically so if you
go all the way back to the founding for
basically the first 130 years of the
existence of the united states anytime
congress wanted to authorize the
government to take out debt they had to
pass a specific bill that authorized
exactly how that debt was to be taken
out
which seems like a pretty good idea
right it puts the responsibility where
the responsibility ought to be with the
legislature that congress would actually
have to authorize a loan or they'd have
to allow treasury to issue bonds for
example but it would be up to congress
congress would actually have to
authorize the executive branch to do
this which makes sense they are the
legislative branch the executive branch
is the executive branch and then in
about 1917 congress decided they were
going to abdicate responsibility on this
thing by creating the debt ceiling that
at ceiling the idea was that they would
just tell the executive branch how much
debt they were authorized to take out
right now attached to a war it makes a
certain amount of sense you would assume
because the executive branch is running
the war the executive branch needs to
take out more debt on a short-term basis
because obviously there are battle
contingencies but in the middle of a not
war getting rid of the specific
authorization for taking out debt is
really just a way for congress to kick
the can down the road without actually
having to be held responsible for doing
any of this stuff like imagine that
every time congress passed a spending
bill they also had to pass a bill saying
we authorized the treasury department to
take out this amount of debt on the open
market it would make everybody think for
just a second is this actually worth it
congress doesn't want you to think is it
actually worth it so instead they pass
these giant blunderbuss packages and
they raise the debt ceiling at the same
time okay well that was the rule
up until about the 1970s okay then in
the 1970s there was a a problem which
was that the
the government kept running up against
the debt ceiling
so dick gephardt created dick part was a
former
congressperson from iowa gephardt
imposed the so-called gephardt rule okay
this was a rule that suggested the debt
ceiling was automatically raised anytime
a budget was passed you didn't actually
have to pass a separate debt ceiling
bill you would just pass the budget and
that itself would be the authorization
for the government to take out
additional debt then during the gingrich
revolution of the 90s this was reversed
so in 1995 congress said no we're not
doing it this way anymore we are not
going to simply pretend that every time
we authorize spending the federal
government has the ability to go out and
take debt instead we do have to take
some of the blame or credit for raising
the debt ceiling so we're going to bring
back the debt ceiling debate now in
reality we've got to go back to the
original system congress ought to have
to specifically authorize precisely what
sort of debt instrument needs to be used
by the executive branch every time they
spend
the reason they need they really should
have to do that is because again they
should be forced to consider the
consequences of the spending that they
do
but we have both a legislative branch
and an executive branch that seemed to
want to just spend without any sort of
end at all
i know a lot of this is is sort of a
riff on modern monetary theory which is
this idiotic idea that the federal
government can spend as much money as it
could possibly want for literally the
rest of time because nobody is ever
going to see the full faith and credit
of the united states has endowed
we are always going to be the world's
strongest economy we are always going to
be the world's strongest currency and if
we aren't well we'll deal with that when
we come to it
janet yellen who remember was the head
of the federal reserve the federal
reserve was supposed to be a
non-partisan non-political board and it
is their job to
see that the inflation rates remain low
and that employment remains high so
janet yellen was supposed to be this
non-partisan person of course that
chinese fence the chinese screen between
the treasury department and the federal
reserve was obliterated long ago but
janet yellen has made clear just how
fast that was obliterated she moved
directly from the federal reserve to the
treasury department where she has been
now advocating to get rid of the debt
ceiling entirely the idea being that any
time congress just passes something it
should automatically raise the debt
ceiling so we can go out and we can
borrow for it and there will be no
leverage to lower spending any time in
the future remember the debt ceiling
instrument has been used a couple of
times in the past 10 years
in order to lower spending or in order
to
jar certain political items loose and
it's not just a republican thing in 2006
nancy pelosi actually held up the debt
ceiling in order to try and pry
concessions from the bush administration
but most famously the debt ceiling
debate was hit
during the bainer time and speaker of
the house
and the the result was sequestration
which was a lowering of the rate of
increase in government spending in the
federal government is pretty
controversial because barack obama
insisted that half the cuts come from
defense if there were going to be any
any cuts because barack obama hated the
defense department but it was at least
an instrument for attempting to lower
the amount of money we spend now we have
the executive branch saying we want to
spend without end and we don't want any
sort of congressional check on how much
we can take out in order to pay for your
spending so
this is breaking down along partisan
lines frankly you know i'm i'm at least
mildly pleased that even republicans are
not on board with getting rid of the
debt ceiling entirely but here's janet
yellen making the case
would you support
simply eliminating the debt ceiling
um so that we don't have to deal with
this in the future and can focus on real
crisis
yes i would if to finance those
spending and tax decisions it's
necessary to
issue additional debt
i believe it's very destructive to
put
the president and myself the treasury
secretary in the situation where we
might be unable to pay the bills that
result from those past decisions
[Music]
okay the debt ceiling is a natural
constraint on the growth of government
it at least provides a leverage point
for reducing the growth of government
janet yellen wants it gone and this is
the entire theory of the biden
administration there should be no limits
on spending it spends spends spent until
daddy takes the t-bird away and when
daddy takes the t-bird away we hit
austerity measures we we have to
radically increase taxes we have to cut
benefits and this has happened across
europe so it's not as though this is
unforeseeable it is completely and
utterly foreseeable not only that when
you ratchet up the spending and at the
same time you ratchet up the taxes and
regulation which is exactly what the
biden administration is seeking to do
all you end up doing is blowing money
into an economy that is stagnating
that's how you get stagflation that's
how you get the 1970s
you can get economic stagnation without
inflation that's japan in the 1990s when
regulation and lack of entrepreneurship
basically destroyed the japanese economy
for more than a decade
that is i think
a high probability at this point and
even biden is recognizing that he's
forecasting over the course of the next
decade less than a two percent rate of
growth to the american gdp which is a
really rotten rate of growth
okay but you get stagflation if you have
that rapid that terrible stagnation plus
the federal government attempting to
pour money into the system via forced
subsidies
the wall street journal has a piece
today titled stock market september
slump exposes messy underside and again
the economy is not doing well right now
it should be blowing the doors off it
really should be
again we now not only have the coveted
vaccines but now we have reports that
merck is coming out with a once a day
pill that that reduces the
possibility of hospitalization and death
from covert even if you get infected by
so we're coming up with excellent new
therapeutics we already have a vaccine
that is highly effective this pandemic
from a public policy perspective is now
over
but the bible administration can't let
it go
and not just that they are firmly
committed to this fiscal policy which is
really about the reorganizing of
american life along social democratic
lines which has a cost right even sweden
which embraced the so-called third wave
this vast spending vast taxation
initiative in the 1970s they had to get
rid of a lot of those taxes and a lot of
that spending specifically because it
didn't pay for itself
they had to free up their economy i mean
there are studies by which the the
nordic countries actually have freer
business regimens and business markets
than the united states does they have
less regulations they have more ease in
beginning a business in many of these
countries than the united states does at
this point
so the united states is going down a
really bad path right here says the wall
street journal markets tumbled to end
the quarter sending the s p 500 to its
worst monthly pullback since the
pandemic fueled sell-off of march 2020.
stocks began the day higher only to
slump in the following hours the s p 500
wound up falling 1.2 percent to
4307.54 on thursday nearly erasing the
entirety of its gains for the entire
quarter the djia the dow jones it shed
1.6
as well it suffered its first quarterly
loss since the first three months of
2020. now remember this was the year
when everything was supposed to just be
guns blazing gung-ho no holds barred
growth
not really
central bankers who were thinking this
year's rise in inflation would wind up
being a short-term phenomenon aren't
sure how long transitory pressures will
persist strategists who had predicted
another strong quarter of economic
growth are cutting estimates because of
supply chain bottlenecks and the highly
contagious delta variants of kobe 19.
economic data have also been falling
short of expectations citigroup's
economic surprise index which tracks how
much u.s reports have been exceeding or
undershooting estimates fell this month
to its lowest level since june 2020.
the month proved a major setback for
stocks with all but one of the s p511
sectors finishing lower in september
the s p 500 is still up 15 for the year
it managed to squeeze out a sixth
straight quarter of gains the index is
just a few percentage points away from
its record close hit in early september
but
not everything is moving together
the stock market is probably going to
continue to gain but not nearly as fast
as people thought it was going to the
bond market has also caught many
investors off-guard the yield on the
10-year u.s treasury note flooded above
a narrow range for much of the quarter
only to stage a six-day rise above 1.5
percent between last week and tuesday
that was the biggest such advance since
june 2020 the move came after the
federal reserve indicated it was ready
to begin reversing its pandemic stimulus
programs as early as november and
considering raising interest rates next
year given a jump in inflation
liz ann saunders chief investment
strategist for charles schwab says even
though there's all this discussion about
the market being resilient the churn
under the surface has shown more
weakness
saunders attributes the swift rotations
taking place in the market to a bevy of
investor worry she says you have
concerns about the virus you have
concerns about the debt ceiling you have
mixed economic data and you've got
uncertainty about monetary policy says i
don't know that we're going to get out
of this mode anytime soon
and then there's inflation which is also
hitting and not going away remember we
were told this was transitory we are now
in october this is not transitory
inflation any longer this has been
continuous
month on month inflation since the
beginning of the year heavy month on
month inflation since the beginning of
the year now are we in full crisis mode
at this point given the fact that
the the debt ceiling is about to be hit
in all of this no democrats can pass the
debt ceiling anytime they want
they can pass it as a clean bill
if they just brought up a debt ceiling
increase
and voted along reconciliation lines
without any republican support to raise
the debt ceiling they could the reason
that they won't do that is because they
want to save that bullet understand the
reconciliation process can only be used
three times a year
if they use it on the debt ceiling they
can't use it on some other piece of
boondoggle legislation they would like
to push what they did do is they passed
a short-term spending bill that averted
a government shutdown that extends for
another couple of weeks that was
bipartisan the senate voted 65 35 the
house 254 to 175.
lawmakers reached a deal according to
the new york times on the spending
legislation after democrats agreed to
strip out a provision that would have
raised the federal government's ability
to continue borrowing funds through the
end of 2022.
the legislation keeps the government
fully funded through december 3rd which
gives lawmakers additional time to reach
consensus over the dozen annual spending
bills that dictate federal spending
so we are not going to get a government
shutdown at least for the next couple of
months
but meanwhile the underlying worries
continue because the underlying economic
theory of this administration is very
very wrong and very very bad
and it's being driven by the progressive
left which has no understanding of
economics like none at all so nancy
pelosi is ripping mitch mcconnell she
says he's playing russian roulette by
not raising the debt ceiling is he
though because you guys can pass the
debt ceiling anytime you want you have a
majority in the senate of the united
states
as mitch mcconnell himself has said
about the need to address the debt limit
this is what he said last time
don't play russian roulette with our
economy
quote
yet that is exactly what he is doing
playing russian roulette
interesting that he's playing russian
roulette with our economy and with
national security and the well-being of
america's
working families she's so crazy she's so
crazy okay notice russian she does this
now with everything right ever since the
russian collusion crap every time she
says the word russian she's like
interesting that it's russian isn't it
every time she goes to a restaurant and
the waiter's like well we do have this
caesar salad with russian dressing she's
like
interesting russian
what mean you buy this
she's so crazy okay but again what this
has to do with is an overall spending
package and and feeling toward how the
economy ought to work not in conjunction
with reality that is going to lead to
some pretty dire economic consequences
i know what you're thinking it's time to
bin some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video